table de mettre sous le tapis
volontairement le déficit de 3 8
milliards d'euros du fsv
et d'annoncer un faux trouille de 400
millions alors qu'il est en fait à 4,2
milliards d'euros
est-ce politiquement correct de prendre
à votre compte
l'excédent d'un milliard 6 de la branche
vieillesse
après avoir durement combattu la réforme
woerth qui a permis ce résultat s
politiquement réaliste de faire des
cadeaux électoraux de 1,1 milliard
d'euros en direction de l'ondam pour la
future convention pour les salaires
hospitalier mais de laisser la facture à
vos successeurs
avec une dette sociale qui plafonne à
152 milliards d'euros
est-ce politiquement responsable de
matraques et l'industrie pharmaceutique
en les ponctionnant dainville et
dainville 4 milliards d'euros
avec ces questions la cour des comptes
restent dubitatives là le conseil
d'administration de la caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie de la caisse
nationale d'assurance vieillesse vous
ont signifié leur opposition à ce texte
vos président vos prévisions sont aussi
contestées par la commission des comptes
de la sécurité sociale et par le haut
conseil des finances publiques
ces perspectives ne sont à leurs yeux
pas crédible le comité d' alerte vous a
d'ailleurs délivré un carton jaune
alors madame la ministre ma question est
la suivante d'abord confirmez vous le
conventionnement sélective des médecins
libéraux
d'une part comme cela a été signé par
les députés socialistes
deuxièmement allez vous revoir votre
copie avant son passage dans l'hémicycle
je vous remercie
la parole est à madame marisol touraine
ministre des affaires sociales et de la
santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs et député monsieur le député
jean-pierre door
je comprends que vous soyez un peu
piteux puisque nous réussissons nous
réussissons ce que vous n'avez jamais
mettre en place nous mettons en oeuvre
et sociaux majeurs
monsieur marceau monsieur marc sorte
monsieur marceau s'il vous plaît sociale
eh oui monsieur le député l'année
prochaine le régime général de la
sécurité sociale sera coche de
l'equilibre avec 400 millions selon de
déficit mais je voulais le coach et le
député oui on soutient concède bien
volontiers ce qu'elles ne vont pas à la
même fierté ou la même conception de la
fierté en matière de bilan social vous
n'avez pas de leçons à nous donner alors
que vous l'avez pratiqué la
multiplication des franchises médicales
et des déremboursements
alors que vous avez supprimé le service
public hospitalier
alors que vous avez geler les
allocations familiales y compris pour
les familles les plus modestes et cela
sans même parvenir à rétablir le déficit
que vous avez consciencieusement année
après année creusé toujours davantage
mais le plus préoccupant monsieur le
député c'est que lorsque l'on entend les
progrès les projets que vous est annoncé
comme des progrès on se rend compte que
les français doivent s'inquiéter puisque
lorsque l'on vous écoute on entend
certains de vos candidats annoncés
purement et simplement la fermeture
d'hôpitaux de proximité d'autres nous
parler de déremboursement massif ou
encore de rétablissement
de l'âge légal de départ à la retraite
jusqu'à 70 ans
vous le voyez nous aurons des débats
monsieur le député mais clairement nous
n'avons pas la conception du progrès
social et